hey this is pressure locker yesterday
BuzzFeed posted a cookie math problem
which already has over 300,000 views the
quiz involved a series of pictures of
cookies separated by mathematical
operations your job was to count the
number of cookies in each picture and
then evaluate the corresponding
mathematical expression if you'd like to
try the quiz pause the video right now
and you can click on the link in the
video description to see how you do for
this video I'm going to present the
numerical equation which the quiz
corresponds to the quiz has the
following answer choices the problem
however is that none of these answer
choices are the correct answer for this
mathematical expression to understand
why we have to remember the order of
operations when you have a mathematical
expressions that involve different
operations there is a precedence to
which you evaluate first you want to
evaluate things in parentheses brackets
then you will evaluate exponent orders
then you evaluate any multiplication and
division and finally any addition and
subtraction if you have operations of
the same precedence you want to evaluate
that from left to right in this
expression we do have a multiplication
seven times eight we need to evaluate
this first seven times eight is
fifty-six the rest of the expression
involves addition and subtraction so we
can evaluate this from left to right six
plus twelve is 18 18 minus three is
fifteen 15 plus 6 is 21
21 minus 11 is 10 10 plus 12 is 22 22
minus 3 is 19 19 minus 56 is negative 37
and finally negative 37 plus 5 is equal
to negative 32 and that's the correct
answer to this expression and you'll
notice this is not amongst the answer
choices so what were they thinking when
they made this quiz well it appears that
they wanted you to evaluate this
expression from left to right one way
they could have specified this is they
could have put parentheses before the
multiplication so that we knew we should
evaluate all the addition and
subtraction first in alternate ways
there could have been an image of an
equal sign after the 7 so that we knew
to evaluate that first as a total result
before multiplying by 8 now we look at
the order of operations differently we
want to evaluate the parentheses first
everything inside this expression this
all becomes 12 we then have 12 times 8
we have a multiplication which we then
do next
this is 96 and finally we have the
addition which we can then do 96 plus 5
is equal to 101 and this is the correct
answer choice according to the quiz
however as I showed you in this video
that's not the correct answer choice of
the mathematical expression as it was
written thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch around my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Locker and if you
liked this video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description